the original system shocks place in
history has been undermined by its
successors in a lot of ways when people
hear the phrase system shock they
typically think of System Shock 2 or the
game series that led to Bioshock oh and
of course showed an with cameras as my
eyes and nose as my hands I hear as a
fan of the original system shock this
bums me out because it's an amazing game
that was ahead of its time in a lot of
ways what the game really needs is a
modern reboot something that can keep
the already amazing design and
atmosphere and make everything else
user-friendly and accessible for modern
players you may already know where I'm
going with this
night dive Studios is doing that reboot
this has been known for a while now but
they just made it official in a big way
with a Kickstarter and more importantly
it comes with a playable demo featuring
the first 10 or so minutes of the game
my expectations are quite high so let's
see what they got the biggest and most
obvious changes the controls you can now
move around with a mouse like a modern
video game left-click attacks
right-click interacts with objects you
can Crouch sprint lean this all sounds
very basic and obvious but trust me the
original game was unnecessarily
complicated and this simplifies
everything without removing features
same goes with the interface Hut is kept
simple into minimum letting you focus
more on the world while still presenting
all the necessary information and the
inventory is now accessible by pressing
tab they even kept the talking head
screen when you access audio logs which
I'm very happy with and the original
game combat was very basic you saw an
enemy and then you either hit or shot
them until they died and it works the
same here but with the now modern
first-person controls in the game combat
is significantly easier and honestly
doesn't have quite the same dread or
challenge to it that was presented in
the original I'm curious how night dive
studios plans to counteract this to keep
the game challenging Citadel station is
practically identical to how you
remember it was simply more detail added
into each room the original design
layout was so memorable to players that
I would like to see it largely untouched
and that seems to be exactly what
they're doing with a modern-day game
engine night dive can now take advantage
of current day lighting and
FEX adding even more atmosphere that
simply wasn't possible back in 94 it
does still retain a pixelated look to
the textures which invokes the spirit of
the original and is also a style that
can be made on a budget while still
looking good night dive seems to
understand and respect the original
aesthetics of the mid nineties cyberpunk
future that system shock presented let's
hope they can also recapture the magic
of the originals wonderful cheesy cgi
intro hacker begins unauthorized entry
into the trioptimum corporate network a
big part of the original game was this
groundbreaking vo work and what was
present in the demo sounded like it came
right out of the original game but that
might simply be a placeholder welcome
back to Citadel station we hope your
somnolent healing stage went well
welcome back to Citadel station we hope
you're selling stage new vo for show Dan
is planned with the original voice
actress reprising her role as long as
they can get the exact same voice
modulation and handle those unique
little glitches with care I'll be
satisfied
the reboot plans on a more modern take
on the soundtrack citing Bioshock is an
influence with hopeful plans to use the
film harmonic Orchestra I'm a little
less happy with this choice and honestly
that's my personal nostalgia getting in
the way I can't exactly disagree with
the new direction and it does fit the
more creepy haunting atmosphere they're
going for but there's just something
about that 90s MIDI soundtrack that I
really love
there is a Kickstarter goal for the
original soundtrack to be remixed and
included as a downloadable bonus so I
guess I'll have to get my fix that way
while scrolling through a Kickstarter
page I noticed a quote for more
inspector on it that said if you update
the graphics sound and UI on system
shock you have something that competes
directly with any game on the market
today this is exactly how a night to
have studios seems to be handling this
remake and based on funding projections
they will most likely get the chance to
do it only time will tell how the final
product will turn out I can't help but
get excited at wanting this to be a
success system shock is still absolutely
a game or explain thank you so much for
watching this video it was really great
to have an excuse to talk about System
Shock because I just love the game so
much if you are a fan of System Shock or
just someone who has played the demo
recently please let me know what you
think I would love to have a
conversation with you about it and if
you want to see more about system shock
from us please like this video and
consider subscribing to us on YouTube
hey have a great day